i'm busy doing renovations and there's
this entire
space under these stairs dave
come check this out bro hold my phone
what the [ __ ] is that oh my god dude go
get the camera
enter facility here
what facility brew there's nothing
behind
look up did you use the locksmith there
yeah
you think you can pick this thing why
you want to go out of this one
it says don't enter i want to enter this
is likely old stuff
brother who cannot open this thing what
you want to do with the door i can do
like this
this sounds ridiculous but when getting
the building we also
ended up owning a road which essentially
means that
no one without my knowledge has access
to this road
nobody can enter hello yeah this is my
factory here
the back of it
[Music]
and what makes it even more violently
eerie is
this terrible sign 28 which is the
symbol for very dangerous gang here
in south africa and then this
let's take a look at google translate
okay now we're definitely getting into
this building
i believe in order to access this
facility we need to get through
the secret green door
[Applause]
storyblocks is the sponsor of today's
video storyblocks is the number one
stock subscription service and
a long-term partner of mine so just
before we
face our way into this vlog
i just want to say thank you to
storyblocks
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
tunnel
[Music]
just to start off this building that we
are in
is more than 150 years old
so so old these bricks are actually made
out of clay
that's why there's a stream running
through here
south africa's scary past has left many
abandoned
or rather better said undiscovered
secret tunnels
that could lead to much needed answers
this entire area
is a black side it's completely off the
grid but i'm going to take the roots of
asking for forgiveness rather than
[Music]
permission
[Music]
i can see a staircase
[Music]
use the back entrance
[Music]
oh there's a latch
[ __ ] there's no way brew this is costly
this tunnel solidifies that something
undercover is going on
next door and i'm not going to sleep
until i get these answers
hello pickle pud how are you
so there's this building next to my
factory space
that i need to find out who owns it
[Music]
i'm telling you there's something
serious going on
so the idea would be to scale this fence
somehow get onto this roof get a drone
an fpv drone something small
through that window lisa unfortunately
couldn't disclose who the building was
owned by so i went through another
source to find out it's definitely owned
by the western cape
provincial government because it's owned
by the government
and i am a south african
citizen that means i can just like
do a little hopperoo over the fence and
and
[Music]
still be trespassing you need authority
you need to get authority to enter up to
the premises you definitely can't do
that
and when you trespass
you break the knot and then once and
then you can get arrested
okay let's get you my lawyer so you can
bail me out alone
it's a there no nothing not to do it in
the first place
so this phone call didn't happen i
should do it and then
phone you from the police station
[Music]
ava come here quickly oh my god
right that's crazy research time
[Applause]
to inquire about a building we want to
figure out what's happening
inside that establishment i'm sure i can
pass you to someone
that can help you now we wait
[Music]
oh i got something hello
yes wondering if you could give me more
information about it
let me just stop it right there where
did you get my number
[ __ ] oh yes the building on maple street
yes i can i can put you in touch with
julie yeah that would be amazing thank
you
then yeah i think we got the number
this is dude this is the weirdest thing
i've got such interesting news for you
that i think this is
very serendipitous i've just got off the
phone with dr adriana marie but she's
erected a bio is it like a white
like sort of sort of thing yes have you
been in there
no i might have flown
a drone through the window i'm not
saying that i did
that's fantastic but i do love your
ingenuity i
love it okay so this is so cool who are
they probably the person that set of the
alarm
oh yeah that wasn't me okay so anyway
yes so to explain what i've been given
permission to disclose
there's this incredible woman named
adriana morae
who has been selected to fly to mars in
2026
she is a singularity expert to advance
the capabilities
of human performance and in this case
moving and living comfortably on mars
those tests are being run out of this
facility
in a dome right next door to my factory
where they are building mars simulators
for weather conditions
oxygen levels and living terrain
i mean you just can't script this [ __ ]
what a find and even more so they have
agreed that i can tag along with them
as they are going through the testing
phases so can you imagine
a vlog to come about what it takes to
live on mars
it's happening and in a serendipitous
act
we got granted our own keys to this dark
side this underground
testing facility let's go come come
[Applause]
this whole thing they're recreating mars
[ __ ] space camera
this is like out of interstellar it's
like an
astronaut suit on a ship freezing cold
burning wind
[ __ ] you recording for your life
[Music]
so in the end i didn't discover why the
tunnel was there which actually just
ended up leading to a wall closed off by
the mars testing facility
but what i did find was so serendipitous
and something you just
can't write it was an act of following
my gut
what a day i'm so excited to see the
synergy
of what's happening in here and what's
happening right
there which is our studio it's like
breaking science crazy person
endless opportunities remember to
subscribe
click the like button comment and other
than that
don't forget you're awesome brew and
i'll see you next week wednesday
wait wait i got so stuck in the story
that i didn't do my brand read which is
highly important because without story
blocks this video wouldn't
have happened storyblocks offers super
affordable subscriptions that give you
unlimited downloads of the
over 1 million high quality assets plus
they're always adding new up-to-date
content this sponsorship doesn't alter
my content at all there's
no red tape and they make it possible
for creators like me and view
to keep up with the ever-growing demands
for modern video content
so bring your stories to life bring your
vision to life by stop
sacrificing due to time budgets or
resources
go click on the link in the description
to sign up to storyblocks today
you